[Musique]
bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
dans Parlement Hebdo votre émission
parlementaire de fin de semaine on va
revoir les séquences fortes à
l'Assemblée nationale et au Sénat avec
notre invité Alexandre bonjour Katia on
accueille cette semaine Jean-François
Husson bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de Meurthe-et-Moselle et
rapporteur général de la commission des
finances du Sénat cette semaine les
sénateurs ont donc voté la première
partie du budget le volet recette une
version largement modifiée en faveur des
collectivités locales
le Sénat qui a en revanche refusé de
taxer les super profits des compagnies
pétrolières et celles qui ont engrangé
des bénéfices avec la crise énergétique
notamment enfin un large oui de
l'Assemblée nationale pour inscrire le
droit à l'IVG dans la Constitution pour
aboutir la réforme doit encore obtenir
la valve du Sénat
et avant de parler du budget une
question sur la ferme McKinsey désormais
sensible pour Emmanuel Macron Alexandra
du Sénat sur les liens entre les
cabinets de conseil et l'administration
publique le parquet national financier a
ouvert deux informations judiciaires sur
les relations entre certaines sociétés
de conseils et le président de la
République Emmanuel Macron l'une pour
financement illégal des campagnes
électorales de 2017 et 2022 et l'autre
pour favoritisme dans l'obtention de
certains marchés publics par le cabinet
américain mckinsec a beaucoup travaillé
pour le gouvernement ces dernières
années Jean-François Husson comment vous
réagissez à cette affaire qui vise le
sommet de l'État
je pense que ça pourrait être une un
sparadrap sur
la tête de la majorité présidentielle je
dis je pense d'abord il faut laisser
la justice faire son travail mais on
voit bien que finalement les travaux qui
avaient été menés et conduit par nos
collègues Éliane assassis et Arnaud
Bazin justement à travers la commission
d'enquête
non seulement avait mis au jour un
certain nombre de situations
particulières et vous voyez que il n'y a
pas de comment dirais finalement une
espèce de corrélation et de suite non
pas de droit de suite mais laissons
faire laissons faire la justice mais
soyons vigilants je crois qu'il on doit
être attentif dans toutes les
républiques dans toutes les démocraties
il y a une chose faire attention à bien
séparer non seulement les pouvoirs mais
aussi les liens avec le monde économie
sparadrap dont vous parlez peu
fragiliser éventuellement le mandat en
cours d'Emmanuel Macron bon écoutez il
est trop tôt pour le dire mais mais il y
a toujours un risque ou une probabilité
en effet allez on va évoquer le gros
dossier de la semaine au Sénat l'examen
du budget 2023 les sénateurs ont
notamment souhaité renforcer le soutien
aux collectivités territoriales qui font
et bien elle aussi face à la hausse des
prix notamment la hausse des prix de
l'énergie Fabien Ricard
défendre les moyens des collectivités
face à la crise voilà le mot d'ordre
Sénat lors des débats budgétaires
exemple avec la dotation globale de
fonctionnement au DGF l'ensemble de
l'enveloppe que l'État verse chaque
année aux collectivités le gouvernement
l'a portait après de 27 milliards
d'euros en 2023 + 320 millions d'euros
par rapport à l'an dernier insuffisant
pour les sénateurs qui ont choisi
d'indexer cette dotation sur l'inflation
entre 2017 et 2021 la non d'indexation a
représenté un manque à gagner de l'ordre
de 4 milliards d'euros sur la
trajectoire que l'on connaît
actuellement au regard de la conjoncture
ces pertes pourraient monter jusqu'à 10
milliards d'euros entre 2022 et 2027 ce
bon qui a gagné est intolérable pour les
collectivités qui voient remettre en
cause leurs capacité d'action une
indexation votée contre la vie du
gouvernement et même celui de la
commission des finances signe de
quelques divergences dans la majorité
sénatoriale de droite et du centre une
majorité divisée notamment sur la
suppression de la arriver à eux cette
taxe sur la valeur ajoutée des
entreprises au profit des collectivités
devaient être remplacés par une part de
TVA dans le projet du gouvernement la
droite sénatoriale favorable à cette
mesure pour soutenir les entreprises
voulaient cependant la repousser d'un an
le Sénat la finalement supprimé et
maintenu la CVAE par une alliance des
centristes et de la gauche vous faites
un cadeau fiscal supplémentaire au
grandes entreprises car rappelons-le les
TPE et les PME ne paient pas la CPE
jusqu'à 500 000 euros de chiffre
d'affaires puis 0,25 jusqu'à 3 millions
d'euros et vous transférer la charge du
financement des collectivités sur les
ménages qui paient la TVA nous pensons
que c'est pas opportun et qu'il faut
d'abord faire face à la crise à
l'augmentation des prix redresser les
finances et regarder ensuite regarder
ensuite cette question des impôts de
production pour aider les communes face
à la crise de l'énergie le Sénat a
élargi le filet de sécurité prolongé en
2023 il prévoit que l'État prenne en
charge la moitié de l'augmentation des
dépenses énergétiques des communes les
plus en difficulté les sénateurs ont
voté l'extension du dispositif pour que
toutes les communes puissent en
bénéficier contre l'avis du gouvernement
moi j'aimerais pouvoir dire que l'État
peut compenser
l'essentiel de l'augmentation de la
facture des collectivités des
entreprises j'aimerais pouvoir le dire
je mentirais en le disant enfin le Sénat
a voté une baisse de la TVA sur les
transports collectifs de 10 à 5 et demi
pour cent afin de contenir la hausse des
tarifs pour les usagers Jean-François
Husson on l'a vu une majorité de
sénateurs de gauche et de cette
centriste ont rejeté la principale
réforme de compétitivité du second
quinquennat d'Emmanuel Macron à savoir
la suppression de la c.ae cette impôt
sur les entreprises qui est perçue par
les collectivités ça leur a apporté 8
milliards d'euros l'an dernier vous
regrettez le rejet de cette réforme oui
bien sûr je le regrette parce que la
réforme
devait se faire en deux temps en tous
les cas c'était notre proposition c'est
la proposition que je portais
premièrement parce que c'est quand même
8 milliards et je rappelle je rappelle
quand même que la France est en Europe
plus en médaille médaille d'argent sur
le poids des prélèvements obligatoires
juste derrière le Danemark ce qui veut
dire qu'on a un déficit de compétitivité
la mesure doit produire 8 milliards de
baisse d'impôts nous avions proposé un
accord en deux temps d'abord en décalant
d'un an la prise d'effet de cette
réforme faite sur deux ans et surtout
parce que le plus important c'était en
contrepartie de cet accord une
compensation bien pensée et sur laquelle
les collectivités donnaient leur accord
aujourd'hui le dispositif n'est pas
abouti et pour permettre ça pendant deux
ans on a proposé qu'il y ait un
dégrèvement c'est-à-dire que
l'effet était neutre pour les
collectivités territoriales ce qui
permet au gouvernement de bien
travailler préparer sa copie parce que
il faut se rappeler que les
collectivités locales
froide ont bien en mémoire le problème
de la taxe d'habitation et des
conditions dans lesquelles elle a été
annulée alors une question peut-être un
peu plus politique Jean-François aussi
sur ses sénateurs centrices que l'on a
vu à certains moments de l'examen du
budget s'allier avec la gauche est-ce
que vous sentez que la majorité du droit
et du centre au Sénat et diviser en ce
moment elle n'est pas divisée sur ce
sujet on l'a constaté on en avait
discuté entre nous les sénateurs sont
tristes ont une position différente il
considère que ça n'est pas le moment
alors chacun a le droit de porter le
jugement sur la temporalité ils n'y sont
pas opposés ils disent ça n'est pas le
moment je partage par contre une
priorité absolue aujourd'hui avec les
sciences et je les redis je pense avec
l'ensemble du Sénat ce qui aujourd'hui
est la première des priorités c'est de
permettre à la France de faire face à la
crise énergétique autant pour les
français que pour les entreprises et
j'insiste le monde économique va
certainement affronter de grosses
turbulences avec cette crise énergétique
et puis bien sûr les collectivités
locales parce qu'elles sont le poumon de
l'investissement public en France et
justement sur les collectivités locales
le Sénat a voté une hausse de plus d'un
milliard d'euros de la dotation de
l'État versé au collectivités en
alignement sur l'inflation vous étiez
contre ce coup de pouce supplémentaire
pourquoi j'étais compte parce que je
pense je viens justement d'expliquer je
pense que nous allons devoir mobiliser
des moyens exceptionnels je dis bien
exceptionnel
l'État les collectivités pour faire face
aux bouclier enfin au filet de sécurité
et donc à la crise d'énergie par
ailleurs il y a une revalorisation des
bases c'est-à-dire de ce qui est la
valeur pour le produit des impôts qui
est aujourd'hui importante et
conséquente donc qui est à la main des
collectivités et moi je préfère prendre
le risque de ne pas où le pari plutôt de
ne pas indexer l'inflation parce que je
ne veux pas non plus dégrader les
comptes publics il faut vraiment
maîtriser la dépense publique il faut
faire des choix alors les sénateurs ont
aussi élargi le filet de sécurité pour
aider les communes à payer les factures
d'énergie qui explosent et qui vont
encore sans doute exploser avec
l'amortisseur électricité qui va venir
en soutien des entreprises et des
collectivités qui coûteraient environ 12
milliards d'euros c'est le chiffre qui
est avancé est-ce que vous êtes
favorable à ce dispositif d'abord
l'amortisseur électricité il y a un
point d'interrogation et un préalable le
point d'interrogation on ne connaît pas
encore son mode de calcul moi une
enveloppe d'un dispositif dont je ne
connais pas le mode de calcul par
principe je me méfie donc il faut
vraiment qu'on est très vite les
éléments parce que
le plus tôt possible je viens de lire
dans la presse ou d'entendre que on nous
communiquer les éléments parce que vous
comprenez dans ces cas-là on vote à
l'aveugle et je dirais pas à la boxe si
vous n'avez pas de communication
hier après-midi j'ai au moment de du
vote de la première partie du budget
j'ai alerté le ministre des comptes
publics en disant que le président de la
commission des finances et moi-même à
Lyon demandé très rapidement
à être mise au courant et de toute façon
nous ferons des points trimestrielles y
compris avec dans nos prérogatives de
rapporteur et de président des contrôles
sur pièces et sur place parce que le
sujet est trop important et ensuite sur
le filet de sécurité là aussi c'est il
faut être au rendez-vous tout de suite
par rapport aux dispositif qui était
insuffisants je vais parvenir sur le
filet de sécurité numéro 1 quel est le
quelle est la philosophie il faut
quelque chose de simple de Claire et de
juste simple toutes les collectivités
doivent pouvoir prétendre en fonction
évidemment de l'évolution des dépenses
sur leur budget à comment dirige à ce
filet donc il n'y a plus aucun seuil on
enlève tout deuxièmement
cette après le parce que ce filet de
sécurité intervient après l'amortisseur
électricité il touchera donc toutes les
énergies ça simple clair juste parce que
c'est effectivement pour tout le monde
et ça tient dans le budget et ça tient
dans le budget alors plutôt dans
l'examen de ce budget il y a eu le
fameux débat sur la taxe sur les super
profits qui ont été générés par certains
groupes durant cette période d'inflation
les sénateurs et bien de droite ont
réussi à rejeter à cette idée d'une taxe
sur les super profit une taxe qui était
proposée encore par une alliance
originale entre les sénateurs de gauche
et les sénateurs centrist justement sur
ce point on va écouter le président du
groupe centriste au Sénat qui défendait
cet axe première idée politique problème
il est politique est-ce que on considère
qui a des profits exceptionnels à un
moment donné oui puisque on les taxe
même au niveau européen donc qui soit
nationaux ou européen c'est qu'on les
reconnaît mais on préfère ce planquer
derrière les Allemands derrière les
autres qui eux qui eux dès le mois de
juillet ont organisé des contributions
nationales les Espagnols les Italiens de
Monsieur Draghi Boris Johnson en
Angleterre à ma connaissance c'est pas
des marxistes les ministres
Jean-François ils sont est-ce que taxés
les super profils relèvent pas du bon
sens quand on voit qu'une majorité de
Français se sert la ceinture alors si
mais le mais c'est la contribution sur
la rente infra marginale
en gros c'est simple il y a une comment
dirais-je c'est borné par rapport au
prix des énergies en disant au-delà d'un
certain montant tout ce que les
énergéticiens font comme bénéfice et
repris par l'État donc vous êtes
d'accord avec l'idée d'une taxe l'idée
d'une contribution mais c'est ce qui se
passe avec cette contribution sur la
rente inframarginale c'est de faire
payer et supporter aux énergéticiens y
compris dans les comment dirais celles
et ceux qui les fournisseurs alternatifs
qui dans le marché libéralisé avait pris
des parts de marché et qui se sont qui
ont pris finalement la poudre
d'escampette dès qu'ils ont vu tu
commences à perdre de l'argent cela il
est prévu dans le dispositif qui a été
voté d'aller à partir du 1er juillet
2022 rechercher ce qu'ils ont encore
fait comme bénéfice exceptionnel donc
selon vous il y a déjà une taxe pas
besoin d'en créer une autre alors la
semaine prochaine et bien en deuxième
semaine d'examen du budget les sénateurs
vont examiner les dépenses de l'état des
différents ministères qu'elles vont être
et bien les points de modification
important de la majorité du Sénat on
parle également du budget de l'écologie
qui va arriver bon on en aura plusieurs
on en aura sur le plan de relance qui
touche à sa fin alors qu'on continue d'y
mettre des moyens on en aura même sur le
budget travail avec par exemple autour
de tout ce qui est formation des
milliards mal dépensés le une réforme
autour de France compétences qui est une
réforme non et mal financée non financé
alors qu'elle a été mise en place dans
le cas qu'elle a précédent qu'elle
devait apporter mille et une réponse et
puis vous évoquez le budget d'écologie
nous sommes pour une écologie de
l'efficacité de la bonne dépense pour
permettre la transition et on va voir
l'occasion d'aborder par exemple
aujourd'hui cette espèce de d'ineptique
qui fait que lorsque l'on encourage la
conversion de des véhicules thermiques
au profit de véhicule dit propre on
favorise l'importation de véhicules
produits en dehors de l'Europe écoutez
les Français nous envoient depuis un
certain temps des messages il faut donc
accélérer permettre d'acheter aux
Français des véhicules à portée de
bourse je dirais produit en Europe et si
possible en France donc l'idée c'est
bien de renforcer ce lien de proximité
de faire que ces efforts de transition
soient utiles pour l'économie française
et pour le contribuable juste en
quelques mots ça veut dire que la
majorité du Sénat pourrait diminuer le
budget alloué à l'écologie oui bien sûr
parce que il y a une alerte à faire et
nous allons bien expliquer les
orientations et je je je je j'ai
parfaitement confiance sur le message
qu'on envoie pour accélérer on a vu
tellement de gaspillage avec ma prime
rénov etc il faut entre guillemets il
faut mettre fin aux erreurs
et bien on va prendre tout de suite la
direction de l'Assemblée nationale si
vous le voulez bien ou les députés
examinaient les différentes les 12
propositions de loi et de résolution de
la France insoumise au titre de leur
ordre du jour réservé une séance très
chaotique les députés de la majorité
présidentielle mise en minorité sur un
texte qui prévoyait la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés ont notamment été
accusés de faire de l'obstruction en
déposant des dizaines d'amendements pour
faire durer le débat et empêcher le vote
le débat a été interrompu dans la nuit
on va regarder un cours extrait de ce
chaos parlementaire
vous êtes content d'avoir pu trouver
vous êtes content d'avoir pu trouver une
petite mesquinerie
obscutive pour ne pas laisser une niche
aller jusqu'au bout
tu vas la fermer
[Applaudissements]
chers de cette manière là et depuis
c'est là comment on observe ce qu'on
vient de voir à l'instant ces insultes
dans la musique de l'Assemblée
je pense que ça renvoie une mauvaise
image de nos enceintes parlementaires
comment voulez-vous
recevoir ensuite un message de sérieux
sur certains sujets de gravité on parle
pas dans une enceinte parlementaire
comme on parle chez soi au café du
commerce
pour vous
c'est une question d'éducation et de
respect je pense que il faut apprendre à
se maîtriser
même la majorité présidentielle dans ce
débat a fait de l'obstruction en
déposant des amendements pour éviter que
le texte sur la réintégration des
soignants non vaccinés ne soient votées
ça montre et bien l'instabilité de cette
majorité ça me paraît évident enfin
d'abord c'est plus difficile d'être
serein quand vous êtes une majorité
relative soumise finalement à plusieurs
vous offrez des angles d'attaque à
diverses opposition qui toutes viennent
forcément chercher ou appuyer sur les
points faibles donc il faut maîtriser
l'ordre du jour il faut s'organiser ça
ne grandit pas ça ne grandit pas nos
assemblées ça ne grandit pas le débat
politique parce que il y a d'un côté la
volonté d'aller chercher des sujets qui
font le buzz
première erreur on n'est pas là pour
être dans il faut arrêter cette espèce
de
instantanéité permanente pour faire le
buzz pendant 48 heures et on passe à
autre chose aujourd'hui il y a des
comment dirais il y a de grands sujets
qui préoccupent les Français et
l'opinion publique il faut il faut être
plus serein voilà il faut de la sérénité
si on retrouve la sérénité je pense que
c'est en tous les cas un des
fondamentaux sur lesquels nous devons
aujourd'hui replacer débat public et
politique un tout petit peu plus sereine
sur un autre texte qui concernait
l'inscription du droit à l'IVG dans la
Constitution celui-ci il a été voté à
une large majorité 337 voix pour et 32
contre elle a proposition de loi a été
donc adoptée en première lecture à
l'Assemblée avec le soutien de la
majorité après la rédaction d'un texte
de compromis récit de séances avec Elsa
mondingueva
un hémicycle presque unanime une
proposition de loi constitutionnelle
très largement votée l'Assemblée a
adopté l'entrée dans la constitution du
droit l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse collègue je suis très très ému
à la fois de ce vote et de ce signaler
historique
que l'Assemblée nationale sonore à
envoyer à toutes les femmes de notre
pays mais aussi à l'ensemble des femmes
du monde après un travail trans partisan
c'est la formulation la loi garantit
l'effectivité et les galaxies aux droits
à l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
qui a été retenue mais il aura fallu
plusieurs heures de débat pour aboutir à
ce résultat les groupes de la nupesse et
la majorité étaient favorables à ce
texte la droite et l'extrême droite plus
divisée sur la nécessité de protéger ce
droit et sur la manière Marine Le Pen a
défendu l'entrée dans la constitution
des articles du code de la santé
publique régissant l'avortement tout en
affirmant qu'il n'était pas en danger je
le rappelle pour la énième fois pas un
seul mouvement politique en France
représentatif n'est pour le retrait de
cette possibilité pour les femmes peu
avant le vote final Aurore Bergé a
annoncé qu'elle retiré sa proposition
loy ayant le même objectif Renaissance
sera lié à ce ce texte là devient le
texte de notre assemblée devient le
texte qui doit toutes et tous nous
réunir devient le texte qui doit pouvoir
aboutir parce que nous ne devons pas
finir notre mandat de parlementaire sans
que notre Constitution ait été modifiée
le droit à l'avortement n'est pas encore
entré dans notre loi fondamentale pour
cela il faudra notamment convaincre le
Sénat et justement tous les regards se
tournent vers le Sénat puisque pour que
cette réforme aboutisse il faut qu'elle
soit votée exactement dans les mêmes
termes en te rassembler et Sénat que va
faire le silence que les sénateurs
empêcheront l'inscription du droit à
l'IVG dans la Constitution Jean-François
Husson mais quel est le problème en
France en France il y a pas de problème
on a une on a eu les lois nevirt Weil
qui protège et garantissent le droit à
l'avortement la liberté pour la femme de
pouvoir décider on n'est pas qu'elle est
en fait le fond du sujet là encore
c'était un espèce de la recherche du
buzz médiatique de mettre en difficulté
non absolument pas j'ai quand même dire
pourquoi aux États-Unis il y a un
problème parce que c'est à l'État
fédéral et dans aux États-Unis en fait
c'est le juge qui décide
de ce sujet là en France il y a accord
total donc c'est un non sujet il n'y a
pas besoin d'inscrire dans la loi
constitutionnelle il y en a le Sénat
d'Iran non
le Sénat a eu déjà l'occasion il y a
quelques semaines de se prononcer il
faut faire sur il faut faire il faut
appréhender ce sujet de manière apaisée
il y a le rapport sénatorial là
d'ailleurs dit il y a quelques problèmes
mais ça n'est pas du tout un problème de
droit ce sont parfois des problèmes de
pratique ici ou là il faut remédier à
ces problèmes du code de la santé
publique mais beaucoup plus enfin voilà
bien sûr que non non mais je pense qu'il
faut être comment diriger très serein il
faut arrêter de se laisser bousculer par
des des démarches que j'appellerai à
contretemps enfin une démocratie apaisée
sereine solide sur ses bases et pourtant
Erick dans le débat lundi soir entre les
candidats à la présidence du parti des
républicains a dit que la droite
sénatoriale qui rejette cette
inscription de l'IVG dans la console
dans la Constitution ça fait penser à
une droite ringarde qu'est-ce que vous
lui répondez moi je ne sens pas la
ringardise enfin le jour où on va me
dire que la loi ne vire nevirent puis
Simone Veil et ringarde écoutez moi j'ai
beaucoup plus de respect pour cette
grande dame très grande dame dont on a
vu à l'époque la forte émotion sur un
pas un pas exceptionnel qui a été
franchi et qui montre bien que les
valeurs d'humanisme de tolérance
d'attention aux situations les plus
fragiles sur le droit des femmes
a été protégé par une très grande dame
ça n'est sûrement pas pour rien que la
France n'a pas bougé son dispositif et
d'ailleurs que c'était garanti ensuite
par le Conseil constitutionnel à
plusieurs reprises alors quand on est on
est garant politiquement et qu'on a une
garantie je dirais par le juge du droit
écoutez je crois qu'il faut là aussi
sérénité calme droiture alors petite
question rapide c'est une autre un autre
sujet une autre enquête du PNF qui
concerne cette fois le député elle a
l'air Éric Ciotti une enquête
préliminaire sur le cumul d'emploi de
son ex-femme qui était sa collaboratrice
dans le passé beaucoup de responsables
LR estiment que le PNF est une
juridiction d'exception c'est votre avis
aussi
il y a une chose qui est difficile
aujourd'hui
cette enquête cette enquête
malheureusement elle vise elle a visé
déjà un certain nombre d'élus qui se
sont livrés à des pratiques qui à
l'époque semble-t-il enfin c'est à peu
près certain d'ailleurs où elles se sont
elles ont eu lieu dans le viseur la
droite pour lui dire clairement écoutez
moi je vais me garder de tout jugement
je pense que je ne suis pas d'abord
faire un jugement abrupt politique quand
on ne connaît pas les tenants les
aboutissants je dirais là Joker mais
c'est un joker par méconnaissance exacte
du point particulier on va passer et
bien à l'agenda du Parlement la semaine
prochaine
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et au Sénat la semaine prochaine sera
entièrement consacrée à la suite de
l'examen du projet de loi de finance
2023 tandis qu'elle Assemblée nationale
les dépucelons les députés se pencheront
sur l'ordre du jour réservé aux députés
LR ce sera le 1er décembre avec cinq
textes en examen notamment sur
l'expulsion des étrangers délinquants et
c'est la fin de cette émission merci
beaucoup Jean-François Husson d'y avoir
participé et merci à tous de l'avoir
suivi
[Musique]